you're in the upcoming upcoming movie
the house will ferrel any polar and you
have I'm told you have an incredible
fight scene did you did you like did you
like train we trained for like three
weeks we had this huge MMA style fight I
play like a housewife kind of gone wild
and it was really empowering I'd never
taken like any boxing classes but it's
it started to get me like like thinking
that I could take someone on the street
does that make sense like yeah it's
probably a I know what you're talking
about but that's probably a bad idea
like they're telling you movie fighting
right yeah yeah no it's all stunt
fighting there's actually no physical
contact right yes it's just shot from
the waist so you you do like that and
then the reaction sells it in the
cameras anyway but I I think it gets
your mojo working you know and you're
like on the street corner and you're
like looking at people like what what
you want to go with me yeah my name's
John Legend what no one's gonna mess
with you in those shoes yeah this guy
came up to me on the street I was I
guess it had it had not worn off and I
was about seven months pregnant and I
sneezed and he said bless you and then I
made eye contact and I realized there
was like crazy in them eyes you know you
know how that happens like people want
to engage with you and so he started to
follow me across the street and I jumped
back and I was like hey man it was like
I was just like literally crossing the
street he wasn't he wasn't and if he had
come for me it would have been on like
you know a lot of like yeah so I am so
on his side in this one I don't he was
coming near you
you know we had on weird cargo ship that
will not come up with the trolley
aggressive cargo shorts will not help
you in the trial you know that's not
like Hello shorts and he's guilty
what about TVs all that he's guilty
you